[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica 7 días
este es un magacín informativo 100
dedicado al continente africano mi
nombre liliana valencia aquí vamos una
mirada en profundidad a los hechos de
actualidad de la semana en la cuna de la
humanidad el presidente de túnez caixa y
destituyó al primer ministro hitcher
mesicic y suspendió al parlamento esto
en respuesta a las multitudinarias
manifestaciones antigubernamentales que
se vivió en varias ciudades del país el
presidente del parlamento calificó los
hechos como un golpe de estado
en sudáfrica la sidra de muertos en el
marco de las manifestaciones
antigubernamentales ya supera las 330 el
comercio es el sector más afectado por
los bloqueos y saqueos también se ha
registrado ataques de tipo racial que
dejan varias víctimas fatales
y cada 25 de julio se celebra el día
internacional de la mujer afro latina
afro caribeña y de la diáspora este año
cuando se conmemora los 170 años de la
abolición de la esclavitud en colombia
el ministerio de cultura rinde homenaje
a las 5 mujeres afrocolombianas más
representativas del país
iniciamos entonces con la información en
áfrica siete días y empezamos en túnez
porque el presidente de caixa y el
anunció de manera sorpresiva su decisión
de retirar del cargo a primer ministro
hashim thaci quien aceptó su remoción y
dijo que habrá un traspaso pacífico de
poderes según palabras de mandatario la
medida tiene lugar para recuperar la paz
social
sayed aseguró que asignará a un nuevo
primer ministro que a su vez conformará
un gobierno de transición que ha sido
escenario de masivas manifestaciones
ciudadanas en las que exigen la renuncia
del gobierno que el fuertemente
criticado por el manejo que le ha dado a
la pandemia de kobe 19
reacción en las calles de la decisión
presidencial calles ayer el presidente
de la república de túnez destituyó este
domingo al primer ministro y suspendió
la actividad legislativa tras un día
marcado por protestas
antigubernamentales alrededor del país
la primera decisión es congelar todos
los poderes del parlamento la segunda
decisión es la de quitarle la inmunidad
a todos los miembros del parlamento la
tercera decisión es que el presidente
asuma la autoridad ejecutiva con la
ayuda de un gobierno liderado por un
primer ministro que será nombrado por el
presidente de la república el anuncio
del presidente fue una reacción al
descontento popular con el movimiento
enahda que constituía el principal apoyo
legislativo del primer ministro
destituido jean machi el grupo demócrata
islamista fue re legalizado en 2011 tras
la revuelta que derrocó al régimen de
ben alí una década después es el partido
con mayor peso en el parlamento y la
población lo señala como responsable de
la crisis que asola el país mi principal
reivindicación es que el grupo
abandona el parlamento ha reinado
durante diez años y no nos ha aportado
ninguna solución sin embargo el
presidente del parlamento y líder de
ennahda rached ghanouchi también lanzó
un llamado a sus seguidores a protestar
en contra de las decisiones del
presidente lo que el presidente ha
emprendido hoy no es menos que un golpe
de estado
ante una crisis con distintas caras
política económica y sanitaria no hay
respuestas a la pregunta sobre qué
implicaciones tendrá la decisión
presidencial en las instituciones en los
hospitales y en las calles ya son al
menos 337 los muertos en sudáfrica en el
marco de las protestas que iniciaron
hace más de dos semanas tras el ingreso
a prisión del ex presidente jacob zuma
la nación austral sufre
desabastecimiento ocasionado por los
saqueos y bloqueos también se registran
ataques de tipo racial que agravan la
crisis social que se vive en el país
[Música]
una bulot la mini era un padre de 31
años que dejó a once hijos fue enterrado
este miércoles en su pueblo natal y
nanda murió el día que comenzaron las
protestas en sudáfrica el pasado 12 de
julio tras los disturbios violentos
originados en el país africano
luego del encarcelamiento del
expresidente jay con su mamá su familia
de anunciado que su muerte fue un ataque
racial cometido por residentes indios
sudafricanos
comenzaron a golpearlo cada vez más
fuerte se despertó y trató de correr
porque se dio cuenta que lo atacaban le
dispararon en la cabeza y luego se cayó
después de eso continuaron golpeándolo
lo golpearon lo golpearon lo golpearon
si bien han disminuido los disturbios
algunos ciudadanos continúan armados y
los temas interraciales se acentúan cada
vez más todos nosotros tenemos matones
en la comunidad india tenemos matones en
la comunidad africana no importa cuánto
le hables a esos matones ellos no te
escucharán y si no toleraremos esos
otros trucos
de esta situación de inestabilidad que
ocurre en sudáfrica a la vez que la
nación atraviesa por una tercera ola de
kobe 19 el presidente de cyril ramaphosa
mantiene desplegado el ejército por todo
el país y ya ha advertido que el caos
acentuará más la crisis alimentaria y
sanitaria hablamos ahora de malí donde
falleció el principal sospechoso de
intentar apuñalar al presidente interino
del país así migoya el acusado murió del
hospital mientras estaba bajo custodia
los servicios de seguridad según los
cuales su salud se deterioró el coronel
goit a quien ha liderado dos golpes de
estados menos de un año escapó ileso
después de que el agresor intentó
apuñalarlo durante las oraciones en una
mezquita de la capital bamako malí es
escenario de operaciones respaldadas por
francia en contra del estado islámico
el perpetrador del ataque fue
inmediatamente aprendido por los
servicios de seguridad durante las
investigaciones su salud se deterioró y
fue ingresado en el hospital
universitario de gabriel touré y luego
fue llevado al hospital universitario
japón donde lamentablemente falleció
inmediatamente se ordenó una autopsia
para determinar las causas de su muerte
que no impide la continuación de la
investigación ya en curso en la fiscalía
y es que el presidente interino de malí
el coronel así migoya sufrió este 20 de
julio un intento de ataque con un
cuchillo en la mezquita de bamako pues
está periodista en mali han flores
pianos ahora del contexto del atentado
según goitá el atentado es un incidente
aislado pero se produce del ruido en un
contexto político difícil dos meses
después del golpe de estado del 24 de
mayo que siguió a otro interior del 18
de agosto este fue el líder reductor
goitá y derrocó al ex presidente y vice
a su cargo como presidente interino el
mes pasado y su nuevo gobierno ya está
bajo la presión de la comunidad
internacional incluida francia 28
estudiantes fueron liberados en el
noreste de nigeria después de haber sido
raptados el pasado 5 de julio en un
colegio cristiano sin embargo decenas
todavía permanecen en cautiverio el
ataque a la escuela secundaria en el
estado de kaduna fue el décimo secuestro
masivo en una institución educativa
desde diciembre en esta zona del país
las autoridades nigerianas han atribuido
los secuestros a lo que denominan
bandidos armados que buscan el pago de
rescates y ordenaron el cierre de varios
centros educativos en la zona
el parlamento de sierra leona voto a
favor de abolir la pena de muerte un
castigo que será sustituido por la
cadena perpetua o una pena mínima de 30
años de cárcel el país de áfrica
occidental no había realizado ninguna
ejecución desde 1998 porque desde
entonces la pena capital ha sido
conmutada el último paso para su
definitiva abolición depende del
presidente julius maravillo que celebró
la decisión del legislativo en sus redes
sociales esta corresponsal en marruecos
sociedad catalana no se entrega una
perspectiva de la pena de muerte en el
continente africano
la asamblea nacional de sierra leona
decidió por unanimidad abolir la pena de
muerte lo cierto es que la última vez
que se ejecutó una sentencia de muerte
en sierra leona fue de hace 20 años tras
la guerra civil pero la ley seguía
vigente en el código penal y se seguían
emitiendo a sentencias en 2020 aún no
habían 99 personas en el corredor de la
muerte y la derogación de la pena de
muerte en sierra leona se produjo en un
contexto de movilizaciones sociales para
la supresión de las leyes coloniales aún
vigentes y la reforma del sistema
judicial promesas electorales en su día
también del actual presidente de la
republica julius mada envió y la
abolición de la pena de muerte en este
país se dan sintonía a los avances que
se producen en todo el continente
de las 54 naciones estados africanos
reconocidos internacionalmente mayo 23
que ya han abolido totalmente la pena de
muerte entre los que cabe destacar los
casos recientes de malawi chats y ahora
también sierra leona
por otra parte hay nueve estados
africanos que aún mantienen y aplican la
pena de muerte entre los que cabe
destacar a egipto que es uno de los más
duros a nivel mundial en 2020 en este
país se ejecutaron al menos 100 personas
y el resto donde estados africanos se
mantienen la pena de muerte pero bajo
moratoria es decir que no se aplica es
el caso por ejemplo aquí en marruecos
donde al igual que en otras naciones
africanas a la cuestión de la abolición
de la pena de muerte hace parte de un
debate de largo recorrido finalizamos
con información de la diáspora porque
cada 25 de julio se conmemora el día
internacional de la mujer
afrodescendiente el objetivo de esta
fecha es recordar la fundación de la red
de mujeres afro latina afro caribeñas y
de la diáspora en 1992 este año se
realizó en colombia un homenaje a las
más grandes representantes de la cultura
afro colombiana y en áfrica siete días
hablamos con varias de ellas
colombia es el tercer país con mayor
porcentaje de población afro en el
continente americano y sin duda las
mujeres negras han sido un pilar de la
cultura nacional y en todas las áreas
del conocimiento así lo quiso reconocer
la ministra angélica maggiolo una mujer
negra joven nacida en el pacífico
colombiano
lo que queríamos hacer es significar el
aporte de las mujeres afrocolombianas
las cuales han tenido la capacidad de
superar paradigmas estereotipos y
demostrarnos que la diversidad es el
mayor potencial que tenemos los
colombianos y como nuevas generaciones
apro colombianas reconocer que nuestros
resultados han sido frutos del trabajo
que las mujeres durante años han hecho
en los territorios grandes culturas afro
colombianas fueron condecoradas con la
gran orden del ministerio de cultura y
la medalla al mérito cultural entre
ellas la compositora y cantante sul y
murillo la pianista teresita gómez las
cantaoras toto la momposina y petrona
martínez la lidereza raizal conocida
como mix click y por supuesto la gran
actriz folclorista leonor gonzález mina
conocida como la negra grande de
colombia
no importa
yo
ah
y me parece que significa mucho porque
nosotros somos las personas que estamos
sabiendo cómo esto puede ser un estímulo
para todos los demás veces que sí se
puede que sí se puede salir adelante que
me importa el color
no olvidarse de ser negra no pero
sí
a la cabeza y sobre todo tener dignidad
para el archipiélago de san andrés
providencia de santa catalina es un gran
honor este homenaje que hoy en ellos y
represento
muy orgullosa y muy agradecida también
no pues tenemos mucho que dar mucho que
ofrecer el evento ha sido un espectáculo
conociendo gente que no conocíamos
este año se conmemora en colombia a los
170 años de la abolición de la
esclavitud
por eso el 2021 es denominado como el
año de la libertad libertad de la cual
las mujeres negras han tenido un papel
indiscutible
didier
así finalizamos este capítulo de áfrica
siete días pero ustedes pueden continuar
con más nuestra página web france24
puntocom y información en cuatro idiomas
sobre el acontecer internacional
quédense con nosotros nos vemos más
adelante
[Música]